ROMAN NURIK: And are we live?
ADAM KOCH: Hopefully.
ROMAN NURIK: I think
we're live.
OK, so hopefully we're
now live, and you
all could see us.
Welcome to Android Design
in Action--
Travel Booking and Planning.
Sorry for the screw up.
We're about five minutes late.
As you can see, we're not in
our normal room today.
There was a scheduling
kerfuffle, if you will.
Anyway, so let's get started.
My name is Roman Nurik.
ADAM KOCH: Adam Koch.
Over in London we have--
NICK BUTCHER: Hi.
Nick Butcher.
ROMAN NURIK: Yeah, so we've got
the three of us here, and
today we're going to be talking
about a couple of apps
that fall into the kind
of travel booking
and planning category.
So let's get started.
Adam, if you could select
the slides there.
The first app we're going
to do is Kayak.
And actually, before we jump
into this, I forgot to talk
about what the show
is all about.
Since this is only the fourth
or whatever episode of the
show, we should probably
mention, in this show we don't
really review apps and let you
know what the best apps are to
go download.
We basically look at a few apps
that have been nominated
or submitted it to us for
review by the greater
developer community.
And we take a look at how we can
spruce them up visually,
how we can make some
improvements here and there to
the visual design.
And the apps that are submitted
are actually
reviewed the previous Friday in
the app clinic where Reto
Meier and Ian Ni-Lewis take
a look at a higher-level
overview of the app and how the
overall app can be improved.
But in this show, we look at
the design strictly and
specific screens even.
So let's get started
with Kayak.
NICK BUTCHER: Oh, and just to
say, today we're having a
special focus on
tablets, right?
ROMAN NURIK: Well, that's
right, that's right.
So today we're going to be
talking about apps in the
context of tablet usage, so
you will not see any phone
screens as far as I know.
Maybe later down the road where
we talk about design
news, but I'll be focusing on
7-inch and 10-inch tablets.
So for Kayak, we looked at the
7-inch tablet version, so in
this case, we have a Nexus 7.
And Kayak is basically an app
that lets you do lots and lots
of different things.
It lets you look for flights,
look for hotels,
look for car rentals.
It's got a million features.
These are all awesome
features.
The feature set is completely
broad and expansive.
There's so much you can
do with the app.
But we chose to focus for now
on the hotel search since
that's kind of one of
the key features.
So in this screen here--
you can't really see
my mouse pointer.
That's fine.
Oh, you can.
Sweet.
In this screen here,
you basically--
this is actually two screens.
You have a dashboard, which is
just kind of the landing page.
When you first open up Kayak on
your Nexus 7, you have this
kind of set of icons that
indicate the different
sections of the app.
And then you have kind of
extraneous or separate
functionality, things like
airline directory, airlines
fees, a kind of random
assortment of other things in
the action overflow.
Once you select hotel search,
which is kind of this top
middle icon, you get to
a hotel search screen.
On this screen, you basically
select the check-in dates, the
number of guests, number of
rooms, all that type of stuff.
When you press Search Hotels,
you are then taken to a list
or a map of hotels.
So basically, you can see here
that to search for a hotel,
you have to go through three
separate screens.
You have to first do the
dashboard, then type in some
information about the hotel
you're looking for, and then
see the results, and then
possibly obviously go into the
hotel details.
So do you guys have any thoughts
on Kayak, in general,
or these couple of screens?
ADAM KOCH: I had a couple
of thoughts.
First of all, I love Kayak.
I've used the website
for many years.
So it's great that they
have a solid app.
One interesting thing about
these designs, I guess, is
that they have the parts of
design best practices, but
other parts are kind of missing
the design best practices.
So you've got these gradients,
you've got sort of a
semi-ActionBar at the top.
ROMAN NURIK: The
faux ActionBar.
ADAM KOCH: The faux ActionBar,
as we call it.
And you've got-- the drop-downs
spinners have the
little triangle to indicate the
spinner, but it's kind of
half and half.
And I don't even know if they
would need that compatibility
menu button down at the bottom
anymore because they kind of
have the faux action bar.
So simply switching the target
SDK out might actually remove
that kind of thing.
Nick?
NICK BUTCHER: So my first
thoughts when I look at it is
this says to be it's a web
app masquerading as a
native app to me.
There's some subtle hints
you can see there.
Artifacts like the gradients
and how some of the screens
are clearly just being stretched
up to fill the
canvas, which immediately set me
in a frame of mind thinking
that this app is going to
be perhaps slightly less
responsive than I might hope.
And it might not follow my
expected mental models.
Certain things like if you look
at like the Up arrow next
to the app icon on the second
screen, you can see it's
slightly too big, slightly too
thick, and all of these
things, which may seem very
subtle, but they just hint to
the user that this app is going
to function unlike the
standard apps which we're used
to functioning with.
I'm also a big fan of Kayak,
but already there's a few
uh-ohs going on.
ROMAN NURIK: Yeah.
And actually, we'll talk
a little bit more
about the faux ActionBar.
There's really no reason to
do it anymore, right?
I think actually Jake Wharton,
who is the author of one of
the greatest kind of ActionBar
libraries out there--
ActionBarSherlock--
mentioned you're doing
a lot work.
If you're rewriting it yourself,
you're doing a lot
of work to try to get it to look
and behave like the rest
of the platform.
So there's really just no need
to do it since for backwards
compatibility purposes, there
are libraries like
ActionBarSherlock that just
do the work for you.
It's really just a
drop-in, right?
So there's really no reason
these days to do it.
It's so stylable, it's
so customizable.
Pretty much everything about the
ActionBar is customizable,
so there's really no reason
to have to make your own.
One last thing I wanted to talk
about before we jump into
the redesign is the branding.
So the branding throughout, I
do love the color palette.
There's a strong kind of orange,
dark gray, light gray
color palette, and I'm
personally a huge fan of
single-accent color palettes
where you have a gray scale
plus an accent.
It's really phenomenal.
And I think that they have lots
of opportunities to use
that really unique Kayak
orange throughout.
And I think that what they have
here is one possible way
of doing things.
But I feel like they can
go even a step further.
So let's jump into
the redesign.
This is one possible way that
you can imagine a tablet
version of Kayak to look.
So in the top, you have your
standard ActionBar.
There's no real need for an
up affordance in this case
because this is a
single screen.
You'll notice that we combine
three screens into one
effectively.
At the left, you have the same
kind of hotel search.
And we've kind of redesigned
some of the elements to fit
better into the Holo design,
the Holo styling.
We've also given more prominence
to recent searches.
This is something that Ian
pointed out last week on the
App Clinic.
Recent searches is something
that's really commonly used.
You don't want to lose something
you just did, right?
So if you went into the app and
did a search, maybe you
did another search, and you want
to go back to the other
one, you really don't want to
have to rewrite everything or
reenter all that information.
NICK BUTCHER: Especially if
you've got a property like
Kayak, which has that
rich web property.
So if you're able to sync that
search history from the
desktop to your devices
as well, that
can be a killer feature.
That can save you a bunch of
time, like Google Maps does,
for example.
ROMAN NURIK: Yeah, totally.
Totally.
Sync is-- that's like--
in Russian, we would say
[SPEAKING RUSSIAN].
That's like a whole
separate story.
But sync, absolutely.
That would make this whole
experience just like seamless.
So yes, I have recent
searches.
We simplified the entry
form and used icons.
Actually, the phone version of
the app uses icons, and the
tablet version doesn't.
It seems kind of silly to have
to redesign the same screen
across different--
or massively redo the
same screen across
different form factors.
I feel like in this case they
could have just combined
certain elements from both and
had less work to do when
porting to different sizes.
But anyway, so that's
kind of this screen.
You'll notice that we did some
touch-ups on the map balloons
or map bubbles and
things like that.
But one question is, what about
core navigation, right?
Switching between
hotels, flights,
cars, things like that?
So for that, we decided to
use the ActionBar spinner
navigation.
So basically, at the top level,
you start off with
hotels or whatever you feel
is the most common or most
important aspect of Kayak.
So you can start with
hotels or flights.
We also added notification since
that was in the phone
version of the app.
One minor point is you can
make it sticky, right?
So if somebody most recently
used flight search in Kayak,
then when they back out and go
about their daily lives and
they open up Kayak again,
you can start them
off in flight search.
It's totally up to you where
you start the user.
If you have a strong indication
that they're into
flights right now, then
start them off there.
And then lastly, you have this
area on the right to put extra
functionality.
So in the action overflow, you
can put things like price
alerts or packing lists, stuff
that's not really commonly
used, probably only like
5% or 10% of the time.
So what do you guys
think so far?
ADAM KOCH: Yeah, I think
I really like it.
Well, one question,
first of all.
The diagonal up-pointing arrows
by the search history,
I gather that prepopulates?
ROMAN NURIK: Yeah.
ADAM KOCH: I think that's
a great feature.
I use that all the time,
say, for Google Search.
Especially when you're doing
searches for hotels, you might
want to just change the
dates a little bit.
You might want to tweak
the location or
something like that.
So I think that's great.
The other thing I really like is
Kayak's been traditionally
known for their power
of applying filters.
But on a desktop experience,
you've got a lot of screen
real estate to fit those
filters in immediately.
On a smaller device, on a mobile
device or even on a
small tablet like the Nexus 7,
there's not as much screen
real estate, so it's being
collapsed into that action
button at the top there.
I don't think you actually
mocked up how the filters
would look out.
ROMAN NURIK: No.
ADAM KOCH: The nice thing is
that the screen remains clear
and easy to read.
And then engaging that can sort
of unfold the power of
the Kayak filters.
ROMAN NURIK: Yeah.
So filters actually in landscape
in their current
app, when you tilt it into
landscape, it shows the
filters as a left pane.
It seems like that
may make sense.
In general, we try to maintain
something called functional
parity across portrait
and landscape.
So if you switch from portrait
into landscape, your view of
the world, your view of the app
won't drastically change.
And the things you can
do with the app
won't drastically change.
Showing filters may
be appropriate.
But at the same time, filters
is almost always kind of a
separate action, like filter
what you're currently looking
at or sort.
So if you have both sort and
filter, for example, if you
had a list here, if you had both
sort and filter, then you
should probably have those side
by side since they're
very commonly used together.
Since we're kind of running
low on time, let me must
quickly jump into this
next screen.
So once you get into the search
results, what I thought
here is on a 7-inch device, you
can't really show both the
map in its full fidelity
and a left pane in
portrait side by side.
So one option is you can
actually collapse the left
pane into this collapsed left
pane, I guess, if there's a
better name for it.
This is similar to what Google
Talk does on a 7-inch or a
10-inch device.
And then if you're on a 10-inch
device and you have
this space, then you never
have to collapse.
Or if you're in landscape on a
7-inch, you also just don't
have to collapse.
Lastly--
I know we're running a
little low on time.
The last thing I just wanted
to talk about--
this point that Ian made.
Actually, I think either Ian
or Reto made this, but last
week they talked about this
concept of let me book my
entire trip.
If you're Kayak and you have
access to hotels and flights
and car rentals and stuff to
see around you-- and we'll
talk about that in a second
with TripAdvisor--
do more than just give the
user the option to choose
hotels and flights as separate
parts of the app.
Don't necessarily separate
your app
into separate sections.
So what if you combine this
entire trip planning, booking,
itinerary experience
into one flow?
So this is something that
we mocked up here, where
basically your sections are no
longer hotel, flights, and
cars, and whatever.
Your sections are now
just your trips.
This is kind of similar
to what Tripit does.
And Tripit has a great model
of giving you an itinerary.
It shows you all of your hotels,
cars, and everything
all in one chronological flow.
And people are really good
at dealing with time or
chronological flows.
So in this case, we have the
hotel search, which is part of
this left pane, which is
basically an itinerary.
So as you scroll up, you get
earlier in your itinerary, and
as you scroll down,
you get further
down in your itinerary.
So your arriving flight is above
the hotel search, which
is above the departing flight.
Once you find and book hotel,
that hotel search card, in
this case, it kind of turns
into a hotel booking card.
And then if you're not
interested in getting a car
rental, for example, or a hotel,
you can just swipe it
away to dismiss it.
So what do you guys think?
Does this make sense as kind of
like an itinerary planning?
NICK BUTCHER: I want this app.
I love what you've done here.
I completely agree with what
you say about the grouping
making sense to me.
Rather than having to go in and
out of different apps or
different sections of an app,
you're kind of putting it on a
timeline instantly.
I just get it, and
I really like it.
And it must simplify your
workflow as well.
If I've entered the dates of
my flights, surely you can
infer the date to the
hotel stay as well.
And kind of grouping it
all together makes
that completely obvious.
So I think that's one of my
major takeaways from this
redesign is the way you've
simplified the workflow to
remove steps, remove dialogs,
and have it easier to access.
ROMAN NURIK: Yeah, totally.
And you opened this up to other
possibilities, right?
So if in the future you expand
to restaurants or something
like that, you can add kind of
placeholders for restaurants,
let's say, every night of your
stay or right before your
flight, or something
like that.
You have really a lot of options
a fully managing a
flight or fully managing
a trip.
Actually, one thing I wanted to
call out is Adam and I were
talking about this, and we
struggled with how do add
stuff, right?
So we have this extra action in
the top right that's kind
of add a card.
But, Adam, you mentioned
like you can just
place that in line.
You don't have to necessarily
have that.
ADAM KOCH: Yeah, I mean, you've
already got the Add Car
Rental there, so there could
be just an extra button or
something that triggers adding
a segment to the trip.
Either way, I mean, that would
just be something that would
be discussed before actually
implementing this.
But overall, I like it.
It's cool.
ROMAN NURIK: Yeah, I think
that's a great thing about
this type of thing.
There's so many different
options.
And one thing we should caveat--
and then we should
probably get on to TripAdvisor
very soon.
But one thing we should caveat
is these are just visual
design mocks.
You won't really know until you
actually have a prototype
in your hands whether or not
all this really works.
But these are just some ideas
that we threw around.
So take all of our mocks with
a grain of salt, I'd say.
So with that, should we move
on to TripAdvisor, Nick?
NICK BUTCHER: Let's.
ROMAN NURIK: So first, Nick,
you want to talk
about what we see here?
NICK BUTCHER: My messy desk.
So I've really enjoyed doing
this Android Design In Action
show, where we're trying to
quite quickly turn around some
redesigns from throwing around
a few ideas on how we might
change things based on
playing with the app
for a little while.
So turning that into a mock to
give you a good understanding
of what that might look like.
So for me, one of the biggest
takeaways has been more
sketching the better.
The more time I spend in
low-fidelity [INAUDIBLE]
tools like you can see
here on my desk.
I find it saves me tons of time
down the road, actually,
in Photoshop or whatever your
tool of choice is for
producing high-fidelity mocks.
So here's a couple
of examples.
You can see ideas I've played
around with and the
scribblings out and refinements
here, there, and
everywhere.
And it just saves you tons
and tons of time.
So I'd say, paper, pencil,
sticky notes are
your friends here.
And for me, I found, as
well, bouncing ideas
off of someone else.
The minute you try and
articulate an idea to someone
else, you find yourself
sketching out, trying to show
it to someone else.
You get so much better rather
than sitting down and kind of
plan the way on your own.
so it's been fun.
ROMAN NURIK: And just to call
out, a few episodes ago, I
think it was maybe in the second
episode of the show or
maybe the third, we actually
provided links to some of the
great templates that you can
download and print out.
So you don't have to
necessarily start from scratch.
You can start from one-to-one
size templates that you can
just print out and
start drawing on.
So that's definitely
a good start.
Better than if you decided to
just go straight from pen to
paper starting from
scratch, right?
NICK BUTCHER: Yeah, I found the
templates are great when
you're trying to get a
consistency between screens
because you can get rough sizes
of elements lining up to
get you that consistently.
But if you're just doing it
single screen, I often find
going even lower fidelity, just
a blank piece of paper
can be lighter weight.
ROMAN NURIK: Cool.
All right.
So let's move on to
the app itself.
So this is TripAdvisor.
And this is the dashboard
screen.
Nick, thoughts, comments?
NICK BUTCHER: Yeah.
So this is the first thing
you're presented with when you
open the TripAdvisor application
on a tablet, and
it's kind of sparse.
I mean, we do advocate a kind
of a minimal look and feel.
But I feel like this is taking
it a little bit too far,
especially when you consider
tablets might have a slightly
different use case.
Well, most studies have shown
that tablets are used in a
much more discovery mode when
you perhaps have a longer
engagement time, and you're
looking for something a little
bit more engaging as opposed
to perhaps a mobile phone
experience when you're looking
for snacking experience to get
in and out quite quickly.
So for me, this design felt a
bit flat for a few things.
So just the sparsity at first.
Next up is laying out all the
kind of different verticals
which Trip It offers is--
it's kind of like exposing the
way that they internally
classify the information.
I know whenever I go to the
TripIt service , and I
actually-- sorry, TripAdvisor
service-- and I absolutely
love TripAdvisor.
I use it all the time.
I used it to plan
my honeymoon.
It's fantastic.
But I never have gone and
drilled down, oh, I want
hotels, now I want hotels in
East Asia, or whatever.
I always just search.
Like for me, search is the
key way you can navigate.
So I felt like having the
top-line verticals called out
was almost misleading.
And lastly, as with most of
these redesigns, it doesn't
quite fall into that natural
Android look and feel.
Already the height of the bar
at the top is kind of
nonstandard.
There is some gradients
throughout the application,
and the padding is
kind of off.
The text boxes aren't quite
as you might expect.
And also throughout the
application, I found lots of
extra stuff, which you kind
of get with websites.
So, for example, there might be
links to legal information
and privacy policies, and so on
that you will quite often
see in perhaps the footer
of a website.
But part of the beauty of an
app experience [AUDIO LOST]
can achieve by simplifying and
really concentrating on doing
one or two things really,
really well.
So i found there's a lot of web
metaphors which had been
carried over into the
application, perhaps through
reusing code in WebViews, for
example, that really detracted
from my experience and didn't
really offer any
kind of added benefit.
So we tried to reduce
those distractions.
Any other thoughts, guys?
ROMAN NURIK: I'm at
a loss of words.
That was very well
articulated.
Yeah, I mean, this is almost
similar to the Google Search,
like google.com.
When you go on the website of
google.com, you're just
presented with a search box.
But google.com, when you want
to Google something, you
generally actually want
to do a search.
That's the one thing people
think when they think-- the
average person, when they think
Google, they think of
search, right?
But for TripAdvisor, to me at
least and I'm guessing most
people, they don't immediately
only think of search.
They probably think of
search as well as
discovery, like you said.
What are the great things that
people are saying on
TripAdvisor?
It's a network.
It's a community of content
that's rich and that you may
not really know about.
You may not know what you're
looking for when you get to
TripAdvisor.
So bubbling that up I think
is very important.
So do you want to talk about
the redesign Nick?
In three, two, one.
Wah!
NICK BUTCHER: Wow.
That's some lovely effects
going on there.
Wow, look at that!
OK, so here is what I've done
with the redesign this week.
So there's a couple of things
we've really tried to achieve.
The first off is adopting the
Holo look and feel as we
always tend to do.
So you can see this in the
flatter gradients, the use of
the color palettes while still
retaining the TripAdvisor
accents is a much more standard
color palette, taking
quite a lot of inspiration from
the Google+ app, in fact,
and using standard familiar
iconography, which the user
should instantly be able
to go and pick up on.
But what we've done
here is we've--
while emphasizing search, so you
see we've made the search
box stand out from the rhythm of
the rest of the application
to give it prominence, as well
as like really enlarging it--
I know that's a huge search
box, really--
as well as floating up other
relevant content.
If you go to TripAdvisor's
website, it's full of lots of
discovery mechanisms, so be
that social from what your
friends are up to, to curated
lists of things you might
enjoy or would like to discover,
so we tried to
bubble up that information.
While again, though, it also
retains the information which
is most important to the user.
So just starting from the far
left, we have the user's
information.
So they have this kind of My
Saves area where you can save
information for later
retrieval.
As well, it's similar
to the Kayak.
We've given recent searches
some more
prominence here as well.
ROMAN NURIK: Awesome.
Yeah, then nearby, right?
Like if you're near something
that's really important, you
want to bubble in up.
So if you're on a tablet, let's
say, and you're in a
hotel in London, in this case,
and the Big Ben is having some
sort of event or something, or
there's some sort of event at
the Big Ben-- clearly I know
nothing about London events.
NICK BUTCHER: Every
hour, Roman.
It happens every hour.
ROMAN NURIK: That's true.
So you can kind of bubble
something up like that in a
really visual way, right?
Actually, this is very
interesting what you've done
with the Friends.
So these activity stream where
a friend did something with a
place, like reviewed a place.
I like the interesting usage of
that square space where you
basically made two triangles
overlapping.
This actually works quite
well with OpenGL
meshes, as far as I know.
But anyway, it's kind of
interesting to kind of show
half-avatar, half-thumbnail
of the place.
Really interesting
treatment there.
NICK BUTCHER: Yeah, if you look
back a couple slides of
my messy sketches, you'll see
a couple of post-it notes of
ways of doing that.
Because I had tried pairing
these two images together, and
you could have some overlap,
or may be have it slightly
indented, but it ends
up looking kind
of uneven and jagged.
So that was a suggestion from a
friend, actually, going for
the diagonal wipe, or whatever
you want to call it.
And I quite like it.
ROMAN NURIK: Cool.
NICK BUTCHER: And just a
couple of notes here.
As Roman said, we're not going
to be showing any phone
redesigns here.
You might end up either
reprioritizing or showing
slightly different content on
the phone because that might
be a different context that
users in-- like I can imagine
saying that my stuff-- the
Recents, the My Saves-- is
going to be really prominent.
But some of the big visuals
might be a bit
too heavy for a phone.
You might want to de-emphasize
those slightly or perhaps even
not show them.
I think the approach I've really
taken here is thinking
about this from a tablet point
of view so you're thinking
about these big visual engaging
experiences, so lots
of visuals.
ROMAN NURIK: One other minor
thing, we're running super low
on time, but I just really
want to call this out.
In general, when designing with
photos, some folks may
think, oh, my photo is a certain
aspect ratio, so the
UI element also needs to
be that aspect ratio.
Don't lock yourself
in that way.
Especially for photos where the
subject is in the center,
feel free to use something
called Center Crop, which is
scale type on Image views, where
basically you select the
aspect ratio, and the image is
cropped within the UI element.
So you'll chop off either the
sides, the left and the right,
or the top and the bottom to
make sure that the image
itself maintains its aspect
ratio while fitting within the
UI element.
So I think this works really
well for things like avatars,
like people avatars, where there
face is usually in the
center and photos of Big
Ben, for example.
ADAM KOCH: I know we're
short on time.
I just want to say, I like it.
[INTERPOSING VOICES]
ROMAN NURIK: OK.
So let's move on
to the detail.
NICK BUTCHER: Yeah.
We have one more screen.
So seeing as Ian was having so
much trouble in searching for
Venice in the App Clinic, if you
caught it last Friday, we
decided to take a little
look at Venice here.
So this is what happens when
you search for Venice.
You just get a generic
city-level result.
And I think the original
is a lot better
than the landing screen.
I think they're doing some
good things here.
They're sharing some appropriate
information.
But I also think they
have a problem
with information density.
I think they're showing too
much information as well.
Now I know for me, when
I think TripIt--
TripAdvisor, I keep saying
that-- when I think
TripAdvisor, I think the beauty
of the service is in
the sheer number of
reviews, right?
It can give you this very
intelligently weighted list.
I don't want to get 1,000
results which other search
engines might offer.
I'm mostly interested in setting
a couple of filters
and then just seeing the
top five or ten.
I'm trusting those reviews.
I'll browser the reviews and
make sure they're OK.
So I've really tried to draw
that out in the redesign here.
So we tried to decrease
[AUDIO LOST]
isn't helping and just float
up the things which
TripAdvisor does really well.
So you can see in the design
at the bottom here, we've
retained the same kind of look
and feel, so that kind of
flatter look.
But we've really bubbled up the
user ratings, and you can
see the ranking is given quite
a lot of prominence with each
listing on the side.
And straight away, we've exposed
when you select a
result, you'll see the graph
and the photos and more
information about that place.
ROMAN NURIK: Awesome.
And another thing is that you've
given just more white
space around all the results
on the left.
Again, I think this is something
I bring up fairly
often, but use of white space
is just really important,
especially on tablets.
And I think that the bottom
screen that you've designed
here just makes better use of
white space throughout all the
three panes that are visible.
NICK BUTCHER: Cool.
I didn't get time to muck it up
this week, but I was toying
with the idea of having a third
pane off to the right,
as it were, so when you went
to click on those reviews,
like the little bar charts or
the photos, you could have
that slide in or perhaps
collapse the left-most panel.
Think what Gmail does on a
tablet, for example, where you
might have your labels in the
message, a subject, and then a
message details kind of on an
axis which slides across.
I was thinking something along
those lines but didn't get
time to mock it out,
unfortunately.
ADAM KOCH: Just one very quick
thing is I'm looking at the
designs from across the table
on another computer here.
And looking at them side by
side, small versions, I can't
really see the text or
anything properly.
But the redesign just strikes
me as very clean, and I can
actually almost make out a lot
of the components even without
being able to see exactly
what's written there.
So I think the design looks
really good from that
perspective.
It's very easy to make out the
most interesting pieces of
information.
ROMAN NURIK: It's just a
generally good technique.
Take your screenshot, or if it's
an APK, install it, and
put the tablet 10 feet away from
you and see if you can
just roughly make out
the structure.
You don't have to obviously read
the text because that's
probably impossible.
But it should be clear to you
what the screen does, what
it's information is about.
Here's--
sorry should have
got to do that.
ADAM KOCH: Now I can read it.
ROMAN NURIK: Now you can
actually read it.
So this is that same screen
just blown up.
OK, so since we're super low
on time, let's fly through
Android Design News.
All right.
So first, Juhani Lehtimaki
released a book on Android UI
called Smashing Android
UI in collaboration
with Smashing magazine.
I don't believe it's shipping
just yet, the physical book,
but I think the e-book is
available on Google Playbooks.
I think that QR code takes
you to the book on Google
Playbooks, or the Google Play
store, so check that out.
It's super awesome.
Oh, and Nick gets
a mention in a--
was it in the forward?
NICK BUTCHER: Juhani recognizes
the awesome Google+
community who talk
about Android
development and design.
ROMAN NURIK: Cool.
Next, somebody else want to talk
about the Books update?
Anybody use Books?
I actually don't really
read books.
But anyway, OK, fine.
So Google Playbooks.
The official Android
app was updated.
Actually, the contextual
ActionBar, if you long press
and select something from the
book, like some piece of text,
if it's a location, if it's
a place name, then it will
automatically do a Google Maps
search and show you a little
Google Now style card at the
bottom, which you could then
click and get taken
to Maps for.
It's pretty awesome.
You can also highlight things
and do cool things with
selections and playbooks.
NICK BUTCHER: I think
it's just really
cool little UI source.
It's like a zero or one-touch
interaction.
It's not very clunky.
I don't have to long press
copy or go to the browser
place, whatever.
It's just really taking digital
books and showing you
why digital books are more
useful than physical books.
And I think it also speaks to
the fact that Google Books
doesn't really use too much
skew off the queues.
I mean, it allows for this kind
of interaction, like kind
of using the very heavy skew
off crutches, kind of limit
the scope of what you can do,
how you can extend people's
very well-established mental
models, so I think it's just a
really nicely done
implementation.
ROMAN NURIK: OK.
Adam?
ADAM KOCH: So very quickly,
this is an app-- full
disclosure.
I've worked with Michael
[INAUDIBLE]
before in the past.
But I thought it was a really
neat little app.
It's got one purpose, just
to look up stock quotes.
It's implemented our design
guidelines and the Holo
theming very nicely.
It's also got this sort of card
pattern which you see
around the place quite a lot now
and that we talked about
quite a lot with these
travel apps.
And check it out.
It's very nicely done.
ROMAN NURIK: Much to my and
Nick's delight, I believe
Michael is using either Roboto
Thin or Roboto Light for the
stock quote.
I think it's just--
mwah-- eloquent.
[INTERPOSING VOICES]
NICK BUTCHER: I was indeed
delighted when he
created this light up.
ROMAN NURIK: All right.
NICK BUTCHER: And not just
at the stock price.
ROMAN NURIK: Nick, do you want
to talk about the OP redesign?
NICK BUTCHER: Yes, so Marie
strikes again, really, who
featured last week's redesign.
And the ultimate stopwatch
app has spent one hour,
apparently, mocking up some
redesigns of the popular
European travel app.
Offi, I believe it's
pronounced.
So this is an app I've used
when I visited Berlin this
summer and found it
quite hard to use.
It was very dense in information
and she's really
sprinkled it with some
designer's love all over it
and just really, really help
with the information density,
and it's so much easier
to read and cleaner.
I very much like what she's done
there, so follow the link
if you want to read a
bit more about that.
ROMAN NURIK: One thing I want
to call out is in the right
screen, you have shuttle stops
or bus stops that are
connected by a line
with circles.
I think that's a great way to
tie together chronological
information.
You can just have list items
that say number one or first,
and then next do this,
then do that.
But tying them together using a
single form, using that line
and then the circles, as just
an example, I think that's a
great way to tie them together
and further inform the user
that these are actually
parts of a sequence.
NICK BUTCHER: Good job.
ROMAN NURIK: All right.
So that does it for us.
I think we're about
five minutes late.
That's not too bad.
But anyway, thanks
for joining.
As always, I'm Roman Nurik.
ADAM KOCH: Adam Koch.
NICK BUTCHER: And I'm
Nick Butcher.
Don't forget to tune in to the
App Clinic this Friday when
you can see which apps are next
in line for perhaps being
redesigned.
ROMAN NURIK: Yeah, and like we
said in the very beginning,
we're going to be focusing
a lot about on
tablets this week.
So I believe they're looking at
tablet apps at that clinic
or the tablet versions of
apps in that clinic.
Again, thanks for joining.
See you all later.
ADAM KOCH: Bye.
NICK BUTCHER: Bye.